depuis 3 jours les températures sont
descendues dans le négatif surpris par
les flocons les ivelinois s'équipent
pour affronter le froid rien de mieux
qu'une paire de gants des collants et
une polaire avec l'arrivée des soles
divers plusieurs magasins affichent des
réductions sur les vêtements chauds et
certains habitants des Yvelines ont
décidé d'en profiter avec des ressentis
jusqu'à Mo- 5°gr le grand froid va se
poursuivre jusqu'à la fin de la semaine
pour l'instant on va à l'essentiel avec
le froid qui est qui est là on lui
achète des gants j'attends un peu de
voir si ça va descendre avec les autres
des marques qu'est-ce que tu vas faire
là des bonhommes de neige et peut-être
bancer les boules de neige sur maman moi
demain que je commence au taf et bah vu
les températures qu'il annoncent je je
m'équipe d'accord je me suis pris un un
sous un sous pantalon et puis un un pull
bah un blouson et des gants enfin une
seule paire de gant parce que il y en
avait pas d'autres et pas du solde on a
fait la la réserve de cachcou mes gamins
vont au ski pour le collège et donc j'ai
attendu quand même les soldes pour le
acheter ce qui manquait quoi